gentlemen we have a show for you tonight
and everything okay over there I'm sorry
it's just it's this new chair I can't
get comfortable that's that's that's
crazy Andy you won't find a more
comfortable chair anywhere because that
chair is certified Coosh Coosh
is that like who got that trendy Danish
lifestyle it's all about coziness yeah
kinda but it's something different
I found called Koosh totally different
maybe try the chair with the hat to
really feel the Koosh all right fine
feeling cute not at all
I mean maybe I'm just not a Koosh guy
that's what I said until I tried killers
but after several expensive seminars
Kirsch has changed my life okay but how
are even no cure SHhhh when I see cures
I mean this jacket is comfortable it is
it gosh oh god no Andy listen maybe it
can all be better explained by my Jewish
consultants they've been helping me
unlock the full potential of Koosh
trinket Borton can you guys come out
here for a second
oh yeah um yeah guys can you explain to
Andy exactly what kill is yeah sure
cure is like a soft little kitten that
lives inside of your skin
Coosh is the smell of fresh-baked
Kringle berry pie but you can wear it
like a shoe understand now nope okay for
sure well to better understand what all
is cute we've prepared this short video
watch and understand that yes this is
cute
caboose not cute thank you he was cute
never
ah that's right so so now do you see I
do not know
yeah I got to admit even I'm not sure
what Kirsch is anymore after seeing that
okay well we have prepared a second
video to help you understand the first
one please do so now he's cute very cute
just cute smokey thank you
not cute that's huge why the hell was
happening in that video yeah my god what
were you were you eating people is that
what Russia is son you will see you she
will show you
yeah he'll she will show you
oh I get it
okay guys thanks guys yeah
[Applause]
vol business anyway we have a great show
tonight from
the point is we've been doing this since
1993